getting from uh
b1 to b2 is the hardest longest
part of my language learning journey hi
there steve coffin here and today i want
to talk about the inverted hockey stick
and language learning
so before we get into it remember if you
enjoy these videos please subscribe
click on the bell for notifications and
if you follow me on a podcast service
please leave a comment i do appreciate
it
so
what is the inverted hockey stick
and why am i talking about it well
let me briefly introduce this idea it's
an image that i have used before
and the idea is that if you know what a
hockey stick looks like normally you've
got a long shaft and a blade if you
invert it or turn it upside down you've
now got this
blade that goes up like this and then a
long shaft and when we learn the
language we begin by making although
it's very steep and we're struggling
very hard but we actually do make fairly
rapid progress we
learn some words we understand some
words we can use some words we think wow
and then pretty soon though we are no
longer in this steep climb where we're
learning a lot or think we're learning a
lot we now discover that it's a very
long road before we achieve you know
what we want to achieve which is fluency
understanding movies being able to
converse with people it's an awfully
long road and the the progress is is is
actually quite slow and that's one of
the dilemmas in language learning is is
to keep yourself motivated during that
long slow period that shaft of the
hockey stick so why do i bring this up
now because the other day
my son
because normally we don't go to the
office so much anymore and so the male
comes to my home but some male does go
to the office and he brings home this um
very neatly wrapped package
from the us
from an r rogers
in lansing michigan
and there's actually a pretty steep
postal charge there 22 dollars
and it's addressed to me at my office
and i'm saying gee what is this i don't
know in our rogers and it's very neatly
wrapped
and so then
uh
inside it is this neat package here
uh with tape and then as i open it
you know when you hear noise it's got a
very neat use of a home depot box
and lo and behold i find
a hockey stick
okay now this hockey stick is for short
people because actually in real life
the shaft is much much much longer as
the path to learning languages is longer
but and it has a
a letter here
hi steve a fan of link and your youtube
channel here
i thought you could use a model inverted
hockey stick with a few pointers
maybe as language level indicators to
conveniently demonstrate and
these are are these
different colored pointers this is
unbelievable
all the best and conveying conveying and
appreciation for language learning to
your channel subscribers
and link members russ a fan from lansing
michigan
okay
ross thank you very very much and you
know
aside from the fact that it illustrates
the hockey stick
anyone who's ever considered learning
languages the community of language
learners is so mutually supportive i
mean ross is extremely supportive and
and
you know
helpful and and encouraging and stuff
but so many language learners are when i
go to the polyline gatherings everybody
is so supportive no one creates those
criticizes anyone's level in the
language and everybody's
wants to help everyone there's this
great helpfulness in this community of
language learners so let's have a look
at at what we have here
so this is uh
the inverted hockey stick
and
so let's say
that we have different colors
so when you are really doing well you
know you are basically green
you know the light is green
i think that's what probably what russ
had in mind
and uh maybe that's c1
which is
for all intents and purposes you're
flying in the language
b2
which i consider to be my goal in other
words and for those of you who aren't
familiar with the
european framework i mean v2 means that
you're comfortable you make a lot of
mistakes c1 means you're really very
good you make
few or very few mistakes
c1 c2 is like you're as fluent as a
native basically so
so then well let's make that c1
yellow is
when i approach a traffic light if it's
yellow i'll tend to
stop which is what you're supposed to do
a lot of people just go flying through
it they speed up when they see a yellow
light so let's say that when you're in
the b area
um
b1 b2
you shouldn't even though you're
encountering difficulties
you should speed up
like the guys that run
yellow lights the same just go for it
run that yellow light
now
when you're here
now you know as i'm doing this i was
thinking to myself maybe i should have
made
the shaft
okay
maybe i should have put green colors
there
but i've started this way so i'm gonna
i'm gonna stay with it
so here
with russell's hockey stick
when you start at the beginning of the
shaft it's as if you can't move at first
because you the language makes no sense
it's just noise
uh but very quickly you start to gain
a bit of a sense of the language but
it's still a struggle but it's a steep
struggle and because it's as if you're
if you're climbing
a cliff
and you're kind of
getting a toe hold and you're actually
moving quite a distance up even though
it's hard work it's hard work on your
legs
i don't know why i would go for maybe i
should change it maybe i should
maybe i should but i don't want you to
stop
when you're at c1 okay so let's say that
it's red because there are barriers but
you're going to break through the
barriers and you're going to break
through the barriers as you climb that
steep initial period
in learning a language but then as you
hit the shaft of the hockey stick now
you're in that middle period
b1
b1
b2 i guess this would be but i i should
move this up here because i think
b2 and c1 is so close
that i can't really tell the difference
and uh c2 is almost in unattainable you
know if you get there that's fine you
really have to focus on that language in
great depth to achieve that
b1 or at least b2 c1 are both good goals
to achieve
maybe that's where
you know you run
you run the the trouble is the traffic
light doesn't turn green it turns red
and so if you run if you try to run that
yellow light and it turns red and
there's a cop there
you're in trouble
so
that's not very realistic so
maybe i should have done it the other
way
anyway it doesn't matter the principle
is when you start in the language it's
all noise you work very hard you i
listen many many times to the same
uh content
then i move on to this
shaft of the hockey stick slow slow slow
progress actually i should move this up
here because i think that getting from
getting
from b1 to b2 is the hardest longest
part of my language learning journey
once i'm at
b2 where i can understand stuff i can
understand movies i don't care if i make
mistakes i don't care if there's words
that i don't know because there's so
many things i can do in the language so
i will at some point maybe i've moved to
c1 maybe i'd have to take a test to
prove that i'm at c1 but either at b2
or c1 i'm comfortable
and as i said this other
c2 is just
out of the picture except for the real
die hards that the difficulty is here
when we get to the top of the steep
climb
high frequency
words we're encountering over and over
again we're acquiring these words we
think we're making progress and we turn
the corner and we're in this area here
where it seems like we can't remember
anything
we're not very satisfied with our
improvement anymore and that's where you
got to
put your
you know
foot on the gas pedal run that yellow
light and take yourself up to b2 and
once you're at b2
you can progress as much as you want it
depends on
how much you know opportunity you have
to speak the language if you live in the
country a whole bunch of things like
that so
thank you very much russ from lansing
michigan
i don't know how you intended your uh
inverted hockey stick to be used but i
very much appreciate you sending this to
me and so i wanted to share
it with my viewers and also to thank you
and i will be sending ross a note and i
will also leave you with the previous
videos that i have done
on this issue of the hockey stick the
inverted hockey stick and how we get
through the doldrums that long period
when we think we're not making any
progress
thank you for listening bye for now